après leur avoir tenu tête pendant trois
semaines le Premier ministre a reculé et
a fait Voltaire face bonjour
un comité parlementaire pour savoir ce
que le premier ministre savait des
tentatives d'ingérence de Pékin et à
quel moment il a été mis au courant on
veut construire faire fonctionner le
Parlement on voit très bien que les
conservateurs veulent en faire un cirque
partisan la pression a monté deux crans
quand les conservateurs ont déposé une
motion avec l'appui du Bloc québécois
pour convoquer cat itelford le NPD
menaçait de joindre le franc commun on
ne veut pas reconnaître l'action on veut
savoir que nos élections sont libres de
ingérence et étrangère l'émotion
n'aurait pas eu comme conséquence de
renverser le gouvernement
difficile à contenir pour les libéraux
avant le 23 mai prochain sur la
nécessité d'une telle enquête ici
Valérie Gamaches au Canada
Ottawa